alex a proposé un défi très dangereux à
une enfant américaine la petite fille de
10 ans qui souhaitait s'amuser a demandé
à l'assistant vocal d'amazon de lui
proposer un challenge l'intelligence
artificielle lui a alors proposé le défi
suivant brancher jusqu'à la moitié un
chargeur de téléphone dans une prise
murale qui fait mouche et une pièce d'un
centime au bout exposé de la prise un
challenge dangereux qui peut provoquer
une décharge ou encore un incendie sur
son compte twitter la mer précise que sa
fille était de toute façon assez
intelligente pour ne pas faire ce défi
après avoir présenté les excuses amazon
a assuré à la bbc avoir mis à jour alexa
pour l'empêcher de recommander une telle
activité à l'avenir ce défi était
populaire en 2020 sur tik tok et avait
déjà été déconseillé par plusieurs
autorités locales